et retour en plateau avec l'invité de la
rédaction aujourd'hui brigitte klinkert
nouvelle président du conseil
départemental du haut-rhin bienvenue
vous êtes la toute première femme dans
l'histoire d'alsace président du conseil
départemental depuis la création de
cette assemblée
comment vous l'avez vécu ce moment où
vous êtes devenue la présidente c'était
vendredi
écoutez c'était bien sûr un grand moment
pour moi
mais en même temps c'est un moment que
j'avais préparé depuis le mois de juin
puisque dès le mois de juin le groupe
majoritaire ou l'intergroupe majoritaire
du conseil départemental m'avait désigné
comme la candidate et donc il n'y avait
en principe pas de suspense j'avais
passé tout l'été à préparer d'une part
si tu cette rentrée a rencontré chacun
et chacune de mes collègues en tête à
tête pour voir un petit peu quelles
étaient leurs attentes
et puis j'ai aussi en quelque sorte fait
mes devoirs de vacances en préparant la
feuille de route pour les années à venir
que j'ai présentée à mes collègues à
l'occasion de la séance de vendredi
dernier
on vous a vu sur les images qu'on volait
à l'instant oui bien sûr parce que je
suis élu au conseil général du haut rhin
depuis 1994 j'étais allé à l'époque la
première femme du conseil général et
puis déjà en 94 je me suis dit bon voilà
je suis la première femme
ok mais il ya d'autres femmes maintenant
qu'ils vont trés et en fait ça n'a
quasiment pas été le cas jusqu'à la
parité à part lorsqu'un collègue
masculin avait démissionné etienne
bannwarth du canton de soultz sa
suppléante avait pris sa place
mais sinon j'avais été la seule femme on
vous a vu d'autres femmes dans d'autres
régions qui avaient des postes clés
pourquoi ces silos ronaldo alors je sais
pas si c'est le cas de l'alsace où savez
que je ne suis que la onzième femmes
présidentes de conseil départemental du
rhin dont 10% dans notre pays c'est à
mon avis est générale il ya de plus en
plus de femmes qui s'engagent
merci à la parité au 6 mai
les postes de pouvoir sont quand même
plus souvent détenues par les par les
hommes et pourquoi je les ai vécues cet
été en rencontrant mes collègues très
souvent lorsqu en discutant avec elle
elle me disait ah oui mais voilà je veux
pas prendre plus de responsabilités
parce que j'aurais peut-être pas le
temps parce que j'ai peut-être pas les
compétences voilà on se pose beaucoup
plus de questions quand même brûlé comme
une responsabilité supplémentaire
j'ai envie de réussir comme femme aussi
ou non c'est vous raisonnez pas comme ça
maintenant je raisonne pas comme ça
alors je suis heureuse bien sûr d'être
élu
en plus d'avoir été élu à l'unanimité
parmi mes collègues çà çà mau nord c'est
une marque de reconnaissance
mais pour les pour les femmes je pense
que c'est important que ce soit
effectivement une femme qui souhaite
qu'ils soient à ce poste maintenant
clairement il faut dire que la parité a
aussi changé les choses ça de
l'assemblée les femmes sont très assidus
eux il ya sont elles sont plus assidus
on le sait les petites filles excusez
moi à l'école sont aussi plus
consciencieuse plus travailleuse que les
garçons voilà on travaille différemment
on a ça en nous mais le fait qu'ils
aient cette parité à la fois des hommes
et des femmes est très enrichissant
alors vous êtes vous de calmars vous
avez fait des études de droit l'institut
régional d'administration à metz
rapidement vous avez été au conseil
général du bas rhin
si vous avez travaillé avec dans l'ordre
daniel hoeffel puis philippe richert qui
ont était le président et enfin guy
dominique kennel après vous avez
travaillé à la région avec notamment
l'animation de la politique mémorielle
de l'identité régionale mais cette femme
est une femme d'une fille petite fille
même de politique je pense à votre grand
père il ya ces images qu'on qu'on
découvre qui était l'ancien maire de
colmar qui avait siégé au conseil
général du haut rhin avait siégé de 45 à
80 2 et c'est un hommage qui avait été
rendu à joseph ce grand père vous êtes
dans cette
ligne et ça a sauté une génération chez
vous et c'est une fierté
alors c'est vrai qu'en général on dit
que ça saute toujours une génération
parce que la génération suivante c'est
trop quels sont les engagements des
politiques et ils ne font pas de
politique mais c'est vrai que mon grand
père le dimanche m'amenait quelquefois
des manifestations je me souviens aussi
quand j'étais vraiment toute gamine qu
ils m'emmenaient et là il en était fier
visiter le chantier de la zone
industrielle nord de colmar je me
souviens vaguement de ses champs ou
lusine timken à colmar était et est en
train de se construire façon exacte aux
fondateurs sont des choses qui reste
après alors après coup après coup je me
dis que oui ce que ce sont vraiment des
actes fondateurs mais c'est clairement
il m'a jamais poussé à faire de
politique
il était heureux que que je m'y
intéresse je pense qu'hier au 6 mai mais
il m'a jamais poussé un petit gars à la
rentrée scolaire aujourd'hui
actualité chargée avec beaucoup de
réformes les temps scolaires et de
demander dans les sections d'élémentaire
les emplois aidés comment ça s'est passé
dans le haut rhin est ce que comme vous
gérer toutes ces réformes
aujourd'hui alors j'étais ce matin la
rentrée scolaire avec la rectrice à
guebwiller et nous avons fait le point
ensemble en fait la rentrée s'est bien
passée dans notre département nous y
avons veillé
alors pour ce qui est du conseil
départemental nous sommes nous avons en
charge les bâtiments 1
nous avons également en charge les
agents qui sont chargés de l'entretien
des collages et nous avons travaillé en
parfaite harmonie avec les services de
l'éducation nationale pour accueillir
aujourd'hui au mieux les élèves haut
rhinois on m'a fait part de quelques
soucis par rapport à l'accueil d'enfants
handicapés les problèmes des avs des
assistants de vie
vie sociale malheureusement mais le
conseil départemental avec la une
dépêche a tout fait pour que cette
rentrée se passe le mieux pour ses
enfants aussi
et nous sommes en lien étroit avec
l'éducation nationale
tous évidemment il reste certainement
des soucis ici ou là mais nous sommes à
des coudes pour les régler ou bien on
parlera avec voudrais-je guerre dans
quelques instants d'emploi des
solidarités évidemment de cet espace
très national entre le haut-rhin que
vous représentez l'allemagne la suisse
et on va évidemment parler de l'avenir
institutionnel de l'alsace puisque c'est
le dossier chaud l'alsace eux at-elle
fusionner les deux départements pour
devenir le département alsacien
va-t-elle sortir du grand test
on en parle dans quelques instants et
vous regardez 24 ans en alsace avec
notre invité brigitte klinkert nouvelle
présidente du conseil départemental du
haut rhin on va parler de quelques
dossiers on va parler un petit peu
d'emplois on va parler de ce bassin de
population des entreprises comment les
faire venir et évidemment de l'avenir
institutionnel de l'alsace ça fait
actuellement débat vous avez un allié en
la personne de frédéric bierry votre
homologue du bas rhin lui parle de
renaissance de l'alsace vous vous croyez
aujourd'hui à une ans une assemblée
territoriale d'alsace où vous croyez à
une sortie du grand test en 2021 quelle
est votre position de ping est alors
déjà je dis et je crois que tout le
monde partage que l'histoire l'histoire
de l'alsace la géographie sa culture
aussi font que l'alsace
voilà c'est un territoire particulier
j'ai envie de dire une région
particulière et nous avons la chance la
grande chance d'avoir comme voisin le
bade-würtemberg d'avoir comme voisins la
suisse
en l'occurrence la suisse du nord-ouest
et bals et les économies du
bade-würtemberg de l'allemagne de la
suisse sont des économies
particulièrement prospère
ceci est une chance pour nous et ceci
est une chance pour la france
donc ce que je souhaite dire et mon idée
c'est que l'alsace a tout intérêt de se
rapprocher de plus en plus de
l'allemagne du bade-würtemberg de se
rapprocher et de travailler de plus en
plus avec la suisse et avec bâle parce
que
ces régions beaucoup à nous apporter en
termes économiques
et si l'alsace et prospère
économiquement et bien c'est toute la
france qui en profitera c'est donc ça
que nous souhaitons expliquer que je
souhaiterais a expliqué au gouvernement
et lui expliquer ainsi et expliqué aussi
que du fait de ce rapprochement avec
l'allemagne avec la suisse il ya
peut-être a inventé ici dans notre
région ici en alsace une gouvernance
expérimental une gouvernance innovante
voilà alors aujourd'hui je ne peux pas
vous dire ce que c'est un jeu vient
d'être élue au conseil départemental en
tant que présidente
nous allons d'ailleurs dans les
prochaines semaines nous réunir pour
réfléchir un petit peu plus à quoi
pourrait qu'elle pourrait être ce projet
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement le président de la
république peuvent être à l'écouté d'un
projet innovant et expérimental pour
l'alsace et les emporter il est lié à ce
projet pour pas que ça devienne un
machin politique vues entre paris
strasbourg couper un petit peu tout ça
parce que beaucoup d'initiatives dans la
région rencontre des gens qui dit je
suis fier d'être alsacien vous quel lien
vous allez faire avec
avec le terrain alors justement il faut
pas que ce soit une usine à gaz
j'ai envie de dire il faut que ce soit
un projet qui soit porté ensemble et
quand je dis ensemble c'est pas
uniquement les élus mais ce sont aussi
les forces économiques toutes les forces
vives et les alsaciens le le gros
problème de l'alsace et que jusqu'à
présent nous n'avons pas su porter
ensemble et tous ensemble en projet avec
la référence
à l'époque voilà même si 58% des
alsaciens étaient favorables voilà la
barre était trop et le projet trop
compliqué peut-être pas suffisamment
bien expliqué moi je crois vraiment qu
aujourd'hui à une opportunité qu'il faut
saisir et que le gouvernement est
presque on proche parce que le
référendum il est manqué aussi parce que
la participation a manqué revenir là
dessus sur cette question ça va pas
fatiguer les gens c'est pas revenir
justement parvenir mais proposer autre
chose
proposer aucune organisation
expérimental innovante et très ouverte
sur nos voisins allemands et suisses
le alors je vais rencontrer dans les
prochains jours nos voisins mais je
crois savoir que le territoire de balle
souhaiterait justement que dans ce coin
des frontières des trois frontières on
réfléchisse à une gouvernance
particulière parce qu'il ya de
véritables enjeux dans ce secteur des
trois frontières sans parle d'emploi un
petit peu parce que le temps tourne
comment enseigner grosse problématique
depuis des années le l'emploi se dégrade
en cas l'alsace n'est plus aussi
favorisée que camille l'époque comment
innover comment faire venir à nouveau de
l'emploi comment faire venir des
entreprises dans la région est dans le
vrai en particulier
alors justement dans la feuille de route
que j'ai présentées amis collègues
vendredi figurent trois priorités
principales y en a d'autres bien sûr
la première c'est l'emploi la deuxième
c'est la jeunesse et la troisième c'est
l'alsace alors l'emploi vous me direz
c'est pas de la compétence du conseil
départemental
certes mais je dis que l'alsace quand
même est dans une situation économique
et sociale difficile actuellement et
qu'il faut qu'on se serre tous les
coudes pour essayer de créer de l'emploi
alors le département peu au travers de
ses compétences propres miens j'ai envie
de dire passer au tamis les projets qui
sont les siens pour privilégier les
projets qui peuvent donner de l'emploi
un exemple si on parle de route
eh bien on privilégiera des travaux
d'une route qui donne accès à une zone
d'activités je pense aussi et c'est
également l'une de mes priorités que le
multilinguisme et le bilinguisme sont un
atout extraordinaire pour notre
territoire
et là aussi je veux
me battre j'ai envie de dire pour
développer le bilinguisme et le
multilinguisme dans notre région votre
territoire vous le voyez du côté du bad
temps des regrets du côté de la suisse
et territoires la voulait développer
aussi en avec des synergies avec ses 2
c'est vraiment vraiment une priorité
nous avons beaucoup de points communs
avec nos voisins du bade-würtemberg et
nos voisins suisses
il faut mettre il faut nous mettre
ensemble travailler ensemble et ça n'est
pas que l'alsace qui gagnera c'est la
france qui sera gagnante merci régis
qu'une guerre est venue sur le plateau
ça va passer très vite comme disait en
télévision je veux encore parle de
culture
vous avez un rôle prédominant aux
dominicains de guebwiller à l'opéra
national du rhin quand vous étiez aussi
à colmar on parlera de culture une
prochaine fois vous faire plaisir